[Music]
Wow Wow how you guys doing how you live
and how you feeling so I'm gonna be
honest this day has been wild I am
recording it is now Monday right around
five o'clock free agency tampering is
going all-in I'm gonna try and hit as
many of those as I can Antonio Brown
that went down this weekend I have left
coast 15 thoughts on that then we're
getting Tim Brown on the phone because I
thought it was perfect he's a lifelong
Raider he's the guy and he played for
Jon Gruden house they be gonna do it
John
Tim's gonna know how are the Raiders
fans gonna love a B Tim's gonna know
we're gonna get him and then I know that
all of you saw the alert where you saw
the news item this weekend that said
Dallas Cowboys defensive lineman quits
on IG live while smoking weed I'm gonna
bet that not a lot of you watched it I
did and I don't explain to you why he's
not crazy but first we do have some news
it's official Bleacher Report has
decided the powers that be weighing in
your 1400 submissions that the new name
of this crazy wonderful homie driven
podcast is the left go show thank you
thank you guys I appreciate it close
second was the players podcast and I'm
telling you right now we are still gonna
keep up that philosophy players first
everybody else second that's never gonna
die but mainly look guys thank you so
much for wanting it to be called the
left go show I didn't know about it it's
weird putting your name on something but
I'm telling you this I may have to give
34 percent instead of 33 right now
because when your name is on something
you care about it more you fight for it
you go to war for it you don't care so
thank you with that being said I might
need to change these
I know and listen we're always gonna be
the players podcast it's always gonna be
beans not beef it's always gonna be
grass not turf but amendment one an
amendment to we might need to talk about
and I know that this is shocking some of
you at home amendment one raise your
hand I'll wait
Aaron Rodgers is the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen amendment to
Kyle Shanahan has our favorite coach in
the NFL it's the left Co show it's not
Simms and left Co and I have a problem
with both of those two number one I
don't think Aaron Rodgers the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen I think it's
Patrick mahomes I know it's too soon I
know he's played one season in one game
I know but he's the greatest quarterback
I've ever seen so I'm gonna turn this
over to you guys the homies of 33
percent and I need to know reach out to
me on social I'm probably gonna put a
forum online just to get the official
vote I don't want to do a Twitter poll I
want to sit
I want a left go show poll whoo that
sounded nice so my first amendment that
I'm saying and this is crazy
this is anarchy Patrick mahomes is the
greatest quarterback I've ever seen I
need you guys to weigh in should it
remain Aaron Rodgers what do we do cuz I
am on the Mahomed train I am a mewho me
through and through number two I don't
know if Kyle Shannon's my favorite coach
in the NFL anymore Kyle Shanahan never
came on this podcast in person and I
just need you guys to know that I'm
Petty and I care about the people that
care about me
Sean McVeigh knows my name
so McVeigh dropped a casual left Co so I
know and I don't know if he's gonna be
the guy frankly my favorite coach in the
NFL is up I might need you guys to help
me vote for that too so amendment 1 an
amendment to our on the table and I'm
also saying this and this one's really
gonna hurt me right in the gut I'm
looking for my new football dad yeah
I think I got a retire fill there's just
certain things from the olcha I know
we're gonna have Phil on again okay but
I think I need a new football dad I
can't claim someone else's dad as my
football dad and and I actually think
it's kind of fun who is the old guy that
doesn't get to talk enough that we can
bring on to the show and let it be his
outlet yeah we gonna make Terry Bradshaw
our new football dad what about how he
long he's got a lot of kids I'd like to
be one of them I don't know if I can
convince Phillip Rivers to be my
football dad he's got enough dad stuff
to do but um we're gonna have Charles
Barkley on soon maybe he'll be my sports
dad but I really want a football dad so
three things that I need help from the
homies whenever you go on social
amendment one who's the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen Aaron
Rodgers a Patrick mahomes amendment to
who is our new because I'm sorry Kyle
gotta kick you to the curb bro you're
not my favorite coach of the NFL you're
not I'm sure it hurts to hear and number
three who is gonna be my football dead
all right so I have my phone here my
Bleacher Report app is locked and loaded
there has been breaking news all day I
had to go to an NC double-a symposium
because hey breaking left Co news if you
want to watch the tournament with me the
first week of the tournament Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday I'm gonna be
hosting this thing called NC double-a
fast break it's gonna be on the NCAA
website a few other places it's the red
zone of March Madness and they looked
around the company CBS and NFL and
Turner and they said who do we get that
should do this and they said left go and
you're damn right because it's gonna be
created I just got a breaking news alert
already that Blake bortles will be cut
free now that nick foles will be signing
with the Jaguars what a day
after all that Blake bortles shall be
set unbelievable now the question is do
you believe that any team in the NFL
will go after Blake bortles
oh I can't I don't know who but I have a
hope I have a hope you know uh you know
where his former offensive coordinator
went Green Bay if Blake bortles and
Aaron Rodgers are on the same team it
would be the most beautiful combination
ever they walk out there on the practice
field Aaron Rodgers throws a ball Blake
bortles blinks looks puts the ball down
walks off the field sometimes when you
know you know but in all honesty look
now that it's the left coast show I
don't have to hate Blake bortles anymore
I mean guys we could be a pro Blake
bortles podcast no okay yeah I didn't
think so
all right so here are the moves that
have happened today that I've really
loved and I'm gonna get to the over to
the weekend stuff in a second but I want
it because I know that you guys are
listening this on Tuesday morning or
whatever you do the Lions moves have me
very excited for guys thus far Danny
Amendola Jesse James the tight end from
the Steelers Justin Coleman Nickelback
from the Seahawks and they got Trey
flowers from the Patriots here's the
reason I like these moves as a
collection Amendola on its head look not
that much money he's not that reliable
sometimes gets hurt a lot but when you
factor in the fact that they got to
spend money on Trey flowers and Justin
Coleman it was a smart move to get him
as they third wide receiver behind
Galla day and the other dude that's an
absolute a monster for Detroit as I look
up their roster because I am overwhelmed
with news right now know so he's gonna
join their Marvin Jones obviously Kenny
gala day and they tried some stuff with
TJ Jones but he's a free agent but I
like Amendola maybe going underneath
Jesse James is a blocking tight end fits
the personality of what they're trying
to do extremely well they make Justin
Coleman the highest-paid nickel back in
the NFL he was with their head coach for
two years in Detroit Matt Patricia he
knows what he has there goes to Seattle
I don't know if he's the best Nickelback
in the NFL but
something they needed after those draft
picks of t's Taber didn't work out
look I love Darius lay but T's Tabor it
just it wasn't happening he wasn't the
guy so I understand it but to get Trey
flowers and it's expected to be around
16 to 18 million per year that's the win
of the off season thus far in my opinion
because you need those guys get rid of
Ezekial announcer he has not paid out
but this guy can go in there and
establish the identity of this defense
immediately but to beat out Miami to
beat out Tennessee to beat out all the
Belichick disciples and Belichick for
bella' checks number one front seven guy
Matt Patricia is showing and Bob Quinn
are showing that they're really gonna
try and build this in Detroit and I'm
also gonna say this Detroit that first
game of the year when they blew it to
the Jets and then they had a few good
games and then they they petered out go
and check out the last three four games
of the year for Detroit it was starting
to click I think they're gonna take
another step another move I loved I
loved Eagle side Malik Jackson 3 for 30
with a $10,000,000 guaranteed so it's
really a one-year 10 million dollar
contract him and Fletcher Cox next to
each other Wow Michael Bennett was a big
loss traded to the Patriots but this guy
is younger and I think he's gonna be
highly motivated after what happened in
Jacksonville run defense not a strong
suit wasn't the strong suit of Michael
Bennett either but keeping Brandon
Graham adding Malik Jackson Derek
Barnett comes back healthy love that
signing and hopefully we'll have him in
here soon
one thing I would love to see DeSean
Jackson released by the Bucs get him on
the Eagles to get him on the Eagles -
I'm excited to see where DeSean Jackson
goes but he wants to play for the Eagles
I love Nick Foles - the Jaguars for
about 22 million per season I'm excited
for the Jaguars to have hope I'm excited
for them to get in a training camp and
look at the quarterback position and not
go
we had a hold offenses to eight points
this year because it's bortles bortles
is done the steelers they had to rush
out a b because it was
I'm out the Jaguars you know what they
handled it well
they bring in Nick Foles they move on
from Blake bortles happy for it but the
the move that I really really love in
addition to Trey flowers is Jameson
Crowder to the Jets if he stays healthy
this is an underneath receiver that is
super quick that was great with Kirk
Cousins when he was there last year
banged up quarterback changes but if the
Jets are able to get an underneath wide
receiver for Sam darn 'old who lives
underneath 417 million dollars
guaranteed over three years all about it
all about it
Quincy anoon WA really solid receiver
but he was banged up as well but to get
Sam darn old that underneath guy is what
I love these are the signings that I'm
going really what first one Landon
Collins to Washington six for 80 for 45
guaranteed so it's really a three-year
contract for about 15 to 16 million
dollars a year I'm gonna say this I love
Landon Collins as a purser person and as
a player I love in the box Safety's that
are willing to take your head off but
not for 60 million dollars a year the
markets not there
I mean Earl Thomas is trying to get ten
Eric Berry was at 13 that was the
highest so Washington makes him the
highest-paid safety in the NFL
interesting Josh Norman is already the
highest-paid cornerback in the NFL
Washington spends their money in places
that don't doesn't make sense to me I
also don't know if the gap between DJ
sware injure and Landon Collins is that
wide and they got rid of DJ sware injure
cuz he talked too much
I'm just saying Landon Collins you for
Landon Collins he's a winner because he
gets the highest contract for his safety
and he gets to play his former team
twice a year motivation in the words of
the King TI but Landon Collins I'm happy
for him
I'm happy for Trent Brown who got a 68
66 million dollar deal with 37
guaranteed the most for a tackle in the
NFL for the Raiders
I'm happy for Trent
but that one had all the signs of being
a letdown this is Trent Brown that the
Niners traded away for a fifth round
pick to the Patriots he goes to Dante
scar Nekia arguably the greatest
offensive line coach in NFL history and
now he's going to play and so it was
clear maybe it was an overachieving cuz
he was playing for the Patriots they
this just happened with Nate's older and
now the Raiders are paying him big-time
dollars to go work with Tom Cable I need
you guys to understand something the
Seattle Seahawks offensive line was
abysmal abysmal and then they switch up
their offensive line coach and it all
got fixed that offensive line coach was
Tom Cable Tom Cable went to the Raiders
last season Coleco Semele was one of the
best offensive linemen the NFL in PFF he
dropped it too sick to 66 he dropped to
66 from being in the top 20 with Tom
Cable I don't know why Tom cables still
the coach but this combination of Trent
Brown leaving Dante scar Nekia to go to
Tom Cable and get paid thirty seven
million dollars guaranteed it has all
the signs of being troubling now the
Raiders are expected to release Donald
Penn Colton Miller they drafted in the
first round last year they do have young
big guys at their offensive tackles and
they need to protect Derek Carr if he's
gonna throw to a B I'm just looking at
it and going all the signs are for that
to be disappointing
I'm happy for Kwan exam exam derp
getting four years 54 million 27 and
guarantees about 13 and a half per year
that makes him the highest-paid inside
linebacker off the ball linebacker
I'm just saying played six games last
year tors ACL in week seven Kuechly was
the highest-paid off ball linebacker at
twelve point four I've never thought
that Quan Alexander is anywhere near
Luke Kuechly this one now makes me look
at the Niners the Niners put all that
money in a Jerick McKinnon last year
probably overpaid and he got hurt didn't
work out well quad Alexander played for
the Bucs John Lynch
pay for the books okay he's a speed
linebacker can go sideline to sideline
can fit in nicely I'm just looking at it
and going
if Quan got 14 CJ Mosley is gonna get
damn near 16 them he just changed the
market I think see I think that contract
honestly placed CJ Mosley out of a lot
of teams because now he gets to go I've
done a lot more than Quanah Alexander
again happy for Quan as the players
podcast I'm looking at at Mayock and I'm
going maybe oh no that was excuse me
that was John Lynch and I'm going maybe
you didn't get the right one there maybe
it was a little bit too much but the
thing that's really got me saying really
is the fact that multiple reporters are
coming out saying the Giants are quote
listening to offers for Odell Beckham
jr. if Odell Beckham jr. is the guy then
Gettleman needs to get in front of a
microphone immediately and say none of
this is true
cuz I'm telling you right now the Odell
camp has to be frustrated has to be
because if he's the guy then you go out
there and say something if he's not the
guy then you do exactly what you're
doing you shut your mouth and you listen
to offers but they need to go out there
and go the gentleman needs to be angry
we laugh all the time how he's this like
chroma genie old guy that likes to set
the tone well now's the time to do it
now's the time to go out there with that
accent and go how many times do I need
to tell you people to shut up about
Odell you need to because Odell is
sitting at home right now going who am I
supposed to want to play for right now
probably isn't gonna be the Giants
because if you're not standing up for
him and I know that a lot of you are
gonna go well he should because they're
paying him I don't know if you guys at
your jobs know what it's like to be sent
across the country or to have your
entire family moved or to have to make
an entire new teammates I know he's got
money I know he does
I hope the Giants are calling them and
calming them down I would need to be
calm down if ESPN was rumored to steal
me and I had to move to Bristol
Connecticut I would need someone from
Bleacher boards coming oh there's no
truth to this there's none
because I wouldn't be able to get work
done just think about it in your own
life and stop looking at money like it's
the only thing that matters I'm just
saying
really Giants either stand up for them
or make a deal because it's this is not
how you treat the number one player on
your team over the weekend the other
things I want to touch on from
free-agency great move by the patreon
patrons to get Michael Bennet they love
this guy I don't think Martellus was
serious when he said he was gonna come
back and join him but I look at Michael
Bennett fits perfectly into what they
want to do and to be honest as an Eagles
fan he was unbelievable at the end of
the year I want to give some credit to
the Giants organization I thought their
trade of Olivier Vernon for Kevin
Zeidler was great you get a veteran
offensive lineman to add to that line to
put in there with some pieces that
started working at the end of the year
and really giving Eli and sake one and
all them a little bit more time and also
Olivier Vernon wasn't the piece that you
needed very solid defensive end is great
all-around run and pass Myles Guerin
Olivier Vernon together is pretty darn
special but I'm just gonna say that it
matters more to the Browns and Zeidler
meant more to the Giants that might feel
like a win-win on both sides one of my
favorite signings of the weekend was
Eric Weddle to the Rams
I don't think Eric Weddle is a top
safety anymore I don't think he's the
fastest I don't think he hits the
hardest but I'll tell you what he does
have he's got about two or three he's
got about two or three more years left
of where his brain is faster than
everybody else in the field right now
I went back and I watched all these
Ravens clips about how he would get
people aligned or all those young
quarterbacks on the Ravens that weren't
playing great all of a sudden were lined
up in the correct place and I look at
Eric Weddle and what he can mean to that
defense that's losing their cat their
middle linebacker oh my gosh breaking
news
let me just fiddle this finish this
Weddell news and I'm gonna get to this
breaking news but
Eric Weddle to put Marcus Peters in the
right position is invaluable for him to
be in the same meeting rooms as Wade
Phillips is invaluable he's a coach on
the field which is a very fun phrase to
say but more importantly this is a
defense that can be all over the place
and Eric Weddle can get him set up
breaking news coming in it's not going
to be breaking when you listen to the
pod but DeSean Jackson traded to the
Eagles right after I said I wanted it it
happens the universe is real if you put
out good energy good Energy's coming
back DeSean Jackson is a Philadelphia
frickin Eagle now think about what they
got they got Al Sean the possession
receiver they finally got to Sean
Jackson they can take the top off of a
defense you have a running back
situation that you have to imagine
they're drafting or they're gonna make a
free-agent play they were able to resize
Jason Peters today they got a few of
their other offensive linemen locked up
and you have a double tight end set with
Zach Ertz and Dallas Cotter mainly it's
nice to have a speed wide receiver on
the field that's reliable
Mike Wallace wasn't reliable Torrey
Smith good but not special DeSean
Jackson can still be special and now
don't forget don't forget they get Mack
Hollins back from injury to another
speed wide receiver that was a hell of a
special teams player oh man
plus man y'all saw me vibe and went to
Sean that's my guy
D Jack with C whence I mean they
couldn't be further different people but
I love it ah Steelers trademark is
Gilbert to the Cardinals which i think
is a good move from the Cardinals adding
an offensive line piece apparently
everyone's leaving Pittsburgh and I
thought honestly though the best move of
the weekend was the Jets acquiring
Collette Co semele for a fifth round
pick this is a guy that at one point we
were arguing for two years was the best
offensive guard in football Tom cable
gets there he plummets and you get him
for a fifth round pick give my man Sam
some protection it's a great buy low
sell high opportune
all right so we're gonna have Tim Brown
on in just a little bit but what I want
to do is give you left coast 15 thoughts
on the Antonio Brown trade Nick this is
asking a little bit late is there any
way that you can cue up some drum roll
for these because they're all they're
all great I mean these are these are huh
yeah the number one thing that I thought
about with the Antonio Brown trade is
Jon Gruden would have totally traded a
first-round pick for a Antonio Brown if
Mayock wasn't there like let's be real
Mayock got a Antonio Brown for a 3rd and
5th Jon Gruden would have tricked Jon
Gruden traded a 3rd firm Artemus Brian
like he traded a fifth for who's that
quarterback - they got that played for
Alabama AJ he stinks what's his name
AJ McCarron Thank You Paris AJ McCarron
so Gruden 100% would have traded a
first-round pick for a Antonio Brown
that's a props to mike Mayock way to go
all right second thing I thought of when
it came down to the Antonio Brown trade
let me get the drum roll Nick
dereck cardi derrick cars pool parties
are back ah that's right you know that
Derek Carr and Khalil Mack used to have
pool parties all the time and they play
basketball in the pool
where did Antonio Brown do all of his
instagrams from the pool I'm telling you
that in the next few weeks you are gonna
see Antonio Brown and Derek Carr in the
pool
playing basketball I honestly think it
was a huge reason why Derek Carr fell
off is that his best buddies were gone
and he had no one to play pool
basketball with well guess what Antonio
Brown is in the pool all right my number
three thing I thought after the Antonio
Brown trade Antonio Browns mustache
saved him from going to the Buffalo
Bills think about this Buffalo Bills
there's a deal in place they call
Antonio Brown Antonio says I'm not
coming there and buffalo pulled out
immediately immediately a lot of teams
would make the trade and say you know
what we'll keep them we'll make it work
you know why they didn't when you're
willing to dye your mustache blonde
you're willing to do anything it's
really not that wild of an action but
it's kept us confused and captivated for
weeks hey guys do you really think a B
he's gonna sit out I don't know man you
think he's that crazy
he's got a blond mustache John I think
he will I firmly believe that a B's
mustache and perceived to be off his
rocker is what prevented him and really
saved him from going to Buffalo all
right my number four thing that I
thought about with the Antonio Brown
trade are we really just gonna let it be
in Rappaport slide like like no really
though late Thursday night
it was a long drum roll late Thursday
night he reports that a B is going to
Buffalo and not only that it's not just
a tweet because I'm one of those creepy
dudes that sometimes records people's
instagrams and stuff I mean he went out
there and put a face filter on and and
set it with the face filter though so
it's not just tweets I saved the proof I
have the video of you saying it my thing
is this
I feel like reporters I'm not saying all
breaking news breaking news is hard and
like sources can flake on you but we all
knew there was one guy we cared about
Antonio Brown if Trey flowers and DeSean
Jackson and Nick Foles all signed with
the Patriots it would all get moved to
the B Block if a Antonio Brown got
signed that night too Antonio Brown has
been the story of the off season and I'm
a firm believer that if you say there it
is and it's the guy that there should be
some repercussions and I'm sure there
will be but I think that if you're a
news reporter and you mess up on a story
you can't tweet for a week can't tweet
for a week or you can only tweet about
non football stuff I just think there
needs to be some repercussion because
I'm posting things on the Internet we're
all getting excited and maybe I'm a
little bit upset I think it might have
been the face filter I think the face
filter is kind of because you only do
something with a face filter if you're
confident like let's be real like you
put the little heart emojis you do a
little swiping action that's when you're
feeling a little cocky feel a little
cocky I think there should be some
repercussions all right number five
thing that I thought about why are the
Steelers bending the knee for Big Ben
when he was contemplating retirement two
years ago what Peter King puts in his
article that they're working on an
extension to increase his salary of 17
million a year and lock him up for a few
years this is the same guy that said I
don't know if I got it anymore I don't
know if I want to do this anymore
and now we're at his beck and call we're
gonna get rid of a B we're gonna move on
from levy on bail and he gets a race I
don't know seems kind of crazy to me but
Big Ben we're gonna learn about you this
year bro we're gonna learn about you
we're gonna learn about everybody on
that team I am so excited it's because
for years we've been able to blame
someone other than Ben always Oh was the
OC Oh is a bee Oh levian didn't do the
right thing maybe it is all on you big
bed all eyes are on you so excited for
that the number six thing that I thought
about is the media is split and they're
both right everyone is there to takes on
Antonia Brown either one they're
demeaning Antonio Brown is a crybaby
that got his way and that this is bad
for society or there's the argument that
this is a player that maximized his
value in a league dominated by owner
control both of these are correct both
of them Antonio Brown did not set a good
example for four-year-olds Oh
crybabies but he set a great example for
the young workforce in this world that
knows that you need to get your Worth
and don't have that much allegiance to
your boss because they can fire you at
any time and eventually you need to look
out for yourself both of those things
are true but the thing that I learned is
that players on teams that continue to
delay the inevitable with their salary
cap can manipulate the system there's a
few teams in this league that do it
Washington kept doing it with Kirk
Cousins I don't know
franchise I don't know franchise we
can't pay him 40 million dollars Kirk
Cousins cashes in 90 million Le'Veon
Bell well we don't have enough money
because Pittsburgh has to keep doing
this take advantage complete free agent
Antonio Brown takes advantage there
Dallas Cowboys that's what keeps
happening these teams that keep pushing
back their salary cap concerns those are
the teams where players can really cash
in all right the seventh thing that I've
been thinking it's got to do with music
Viva Las Vegas
Le'Veon Bell is dropping his new album
on Wednesday what's happening on
Wednesday free agency officially kicks
off the name of that album life's a
gamble on the front of the album there
are poker chips there are four ace cards
there's only one team playing in Vegas
next year there's only one team that
loves the gamble there's only one team
that's gonna be around poker chips and
ace of spades and that's the Oakland
Raiders soon to be the Las Vegas Raiders
I see all the signs levy on and a be
together in Las Vegas ready to take it
over album drops Wednesday free agency
starts Wednesday I'm excited pretty
excited all right the number 8 thing
that I thought about after the trade
has the tide turned to where the NFL is
about to make some MBA moves the three
highest contracts in the NFL right now
that are non quarterbacks Khalil Mack
Aaron Donald Antonio Brown hold out hold
out trade demand just saying
Khalil Mack said I'm not coming into
camp traded biggest contract in the NFL
Aaron Donald I'm not coming in a camp
new contract highest in the NFL Antonio
Brown hell no I'm not coming in trade
highest guaranteed for a wide receiver
in the NFL just saying I was around a
lot of MBA guys a lot of basketball guys
today and a lot of them were like oh
it's just like the NBA and I had to say
guys the NFL has never been like the NBA
there's just guys right now that are
starting to make MBA moves could this be
the beginning of players finally
realizing that the only card you have is
to threaten to not play Le'Veon Bell did
it and now he's a complete free agent
did he have to take a year off some
people would say he lost 15 million
dollars I'd say he got a year for his
body to recover and he's gonna sign more
guaranteed money in the next few days
and it's gonna work out in the long run
you have to be willing to sit is the
tide turning number nine
the Steelers could have been holdout
proof and they blew it
the Steelers could have been the one
team in the NFL that could have never
been held out again and they blew it if
they would have held on to Antonio Brown
not traded him and in another year of a
player sitting they would have recoup
60% of his contract
oh that 2.5 I told you last week they
would have gotten back 16 I think 14 or
15 of that 22 million and then after
letting levy on bail sit no one holds
out against the Steelers again now
you're a bunch of Busters now you're
trading Antonio Brown for a fifth and a
third and you're eating 21 million
dollars for the greatest dead cat hit in
the history the NFL and your GM comes
out there Kevin Colburn and threw away
all your negotiation tactics and said
what no it's Big Ben and 52 kids so now
you're a teen that empowers the
quarterback and buckles under the
pression pressure of holdouts where if
Kolbert would have thought about what he
said been smart and let a Antonio Brown
just sit there never would have been an
issue Steelers could have been holdout
proof and now you're a bunch of Busters
sucks that's what happens that's why
it's the players League number 10
Antonio Brown deserved the money Antonio
Brown deserved the money all you guys
always a diva always getting more money
he had a contract he should have played
do you know what that contract was do
you know Antonio Browns career Antonio
Brown was a six round pick in 2010 they
gave him a five-year contract extension
from 2012 to 2016 over that span he led
the NFL in two things catches and
receiving yards I don't know maybe the
two most important categories that exist
and you know where he was ranked in
terms of pay 11th he was behind Pierre
Garcon and dwayne bowe over that time he
got paid less than Pierre Garcon and
dwayne bowe and he was the number one in
catches and receiving yards so you can
hold that when it comes to saying that
he needed more money dude went through
seven years of his career of being paid
like an average wide receiver yes he got
guaranteed money the last few years he
deserved it he needed more genuinely
because when all was said and done if we
looked back at his career earnings and
it wasn't up there near the top it would
have been an absolute crime so he needed
it yes he went under paid for more than
half of his career he deserved the money
and he earned it number 11
a be needed to be a Raider I mean come
on Randy Moss like when he went to the
Raiders it was perfect
Warren Sapp when he went to the Raiders
it was perfect
there's certain guys that have a swag
goo that have this inside fire that's
just perfect and they deserve to be on
the Raiders dudes a Raider through and
through I love it and I hope that
Antonio Brown is seen in an eyepatch
Lefko PR Antonio Brown you should only
do Instagram live for the next two weeks
wearing an eyepatch
embrace it every time you come on the
autumn wind is a pirate every time be a
Raider you are a Reiter
you were born to be a Raider you know
what happens if you scramble the words
and into the letters in Antonio Brown it
spells true Raider don't look it up just
trust me
number 12
Antonio Brown in Vegas is gonna be very
intense very intense like he is the star
he is gonna be the guy that you're gonna
see billboards on the road that say
business is booming you know he's gonna
be up there he's gonna be the celebrity
he rides ridiculous cars I mean he
spends his money and that's what Vegas
is it's a town where you need to spend
your money to have fun and Antonio Brown
is gonna spend that money I mean he's
gonna have now we're not just talking
about pool parties Oh Derek Carr and
Antonio Brown have pool parties well
guess what we're doing it at the Hard
Rock and we're doing it with 7,000 of
their closest friends Antonio Brown is
the player that the NFL needed to be the
ambassador for Las Vegas you can't go to
Las Vegas with Derek Carr as your
spokesperson he's too religious I'm not
saying he's too religious but he's a
little bit of religious for Vegas why do
I say that
because people get married in a
drive-through in Vegas they're not
thinking about the chapel they're not
thinking about the Testaments neither
does Antonio Brown Antonio Brown is
about to go to Vegas and be the perfect
ambassador very excited number 13 this
is all gonna probably go really bad this
is all gonna go horribly wrong like all
the things that I love about this are
the reason why all of this trade is
going to go bad like everything from his
relationship with Jon Gruden everything
to like is Derek Carr even gonna be
there even though they're friends to
Antonio Brown being in Vegas there are
so many ways that this could go bad and
if you made me bet it's gonna go bad but
I also think there's gonna be like six
games where it's amazing like I think
that in the beginning of this year it's
gonna be awesome
I think training camp this year is gonna
go smooth and why because of number 15
Thank You Antonio Brown should
practically change his name to Johnson
because there's two guys in the past
that he needs to look at and we need to
look at as a blueprint of what's about
to happen
the first Johnson Keshawn Keshawn big
name wide receiver stud in his own time
first pick in the draft his first year
with Jon Gruden went amazing there on
the sidelines of the Super Bowl hugging
and dancing and it was perfect second
year went so bad their relationship that
they deactivated him for the final seven
games of the year and then he went to
the Cowboys this is a lesson for all of
us and it should be a lesson for Antonio
Brown and for Jon Gruden this first year
will be fine that second year Gruden is
gonna wear on Antonio and Antonio is
gonna wear on Gruden just like what
happened with Keyshawn Johnson a strong
personality in the wide receiving corps
it's a lesson that all of us should look
at so even if it's not on the field
between him and the coach that second
year will be tumultuous its history it
repeats itself the other Johnson is Chad
and this is what I want you guys to
realize Chad Johnson and Antonio Brown
it's a little alarming right now than if
Antonio Brown retired his stats compared
to eight - Chad's are almost identical
through one two three four five six
seven eight nine seasons Antonio Brown
has 1,100 207 yards through one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
pretty much seasons because that New
England was a mess Chad Johnson 11050
nine yards same range Chad Johnson in
terms of touchdowns my man had 82
Antonio Brown 74 same range catches 837
- 766 Antonio Browns a little bit higher
almost everything because he's a better
receiver but here's what happened to
that caught my eye 1,000 yard receipt
receiving seasons Chad Johnson had one
two three four five six seven Antonio
Brown has had one two three four five
six seven seven both with the team that
drafted them and built them but then
what happened to Chad Johnson he went
off on his own he went to New England
with an older head coach that needed him
to play a role it didn't go so well then
he went to Miami then there was an off
the field issue and we never heard from
him again
Antonio Brown is in the same spot that
Chad Johnson was when he was leaving the
Bengals going to a team that Wow if this
works well with Jon Gruden if this works
well with Bill Belichick they know how
to use him this could be great
didn't work out work out well something
off the field happen and we never heard
of him again
so Keyshawn the warning sign is the
relationship between Gruden and a B we
need to be careful the thing with
Antonio Brown is he's going to Vegas
he's going to Oakland and he's had
numerous off the field issues already
none of them have been too big to just
take him out of his career but I'm just
saying Antonio Brown off the field
it could go Chad's way I'm just saying
history repeats itself and there are two
guys that have been in very similar
situations to a B both of those didn't
end well we'll see if a B can be
different and the number 15 thing that I
thought about when it comes to the
Antonio Brown trade of him going to the
Raiders god bless you a B because we had
nothing to talk about man
otherwise I'm breaking down Carlos Hyde
signing with the Chiefs
so Thank You Antonio Brown for creating
a spectacle that we've never seen before
thank you for ver instagram liveing all
the time for dyeing your mustache for
going on the shop for sitting down for
an hour in your mansion with esp
and and calling out the GM thank you
because not everyone the NFL can capture
our attention for this long and in this
time of the year boy do we need it so
Thank You Antonia Brown now let's get a
little bit more context that's not as
much joking and bring on the Hall of
Famer Tim Brown so here he is the Hall
of Famer the gold jacket where the
smoothest hands I ever did see
Tim Brown mr. Raider and until I thought
you were the perfect guy to talk to
Antonio Brown shares your last name
traded to your former team and playing
for your former coach and I need to know
what you think about the whole thing I
think it's awesome and you know I had a
opportunity talk to Antonio Saturday
morning hmm before the deal was done and
just ask some questions for him and
really try and get his mind set on
coming to Oakland man cuz I'm telling
them look I know you played for a very
good very proud fan base but this great
and they suspect they don't play so
though come out here a second second a
job in man but but this kid is ready man
he's ready to come and prove himself to
the rest of the league and to everybody
that's been talking about him the last
couple months that that you know he's a
guy that wants to wants to be great man
so I'm looking forward to seeing him in
the silver and black
what could you sense from his voice on
that phone call about where he is right
now
and his and his excitement for the
Raiders yeah I think that's just it man
he's really excited you know I mean he
just gets it over and over again man I
just can't wait I can't wait you know I
mean I got a fresh start you know I can
give what a coach he wants me to do XYZ
and you know all these great things that
he can do and you know I think from that
standpoint you know you know football
season can't come quick enough for him
and it's going to be very interesting to
see how this old things gel together
with him and derrick karr and the rest
of the guys but you know with your great
football player man it doesn't matter
who's throwing the ball you know you you
catch the ball and do what you got to do
you know III think it's fair to say that
while you share the same last name as
him your two personalities couldn't be
further from
different and I'm curious what did you
think of the whole process from the
mustache to the media to just the last
month what was your view of it
before he came to the Rangers well you
know quite frankly you know what people
around me I kept saying I hope this
thing ends quickly for him because as
each day goes by it seemed to get worse
and worse as far as you know what he was
doing to his it's value in the league
you know so but like they say only takes
one right you know six one two to think
your value is still at a certain number
and and he was able to get that done so
you know look I think you do certain
things that's that's the beauty of the
curse of associate media at this point
you know where you can get on social
media and the whole world knows exactly
what you think in second so you know it
worked out for them you know of course I
probably would have done it that way and
but at the same time you know this is
the world that we're living in no and I
think you know these guys if you can
successfully do it it works out great
but I just wouldn't recommend everybody
doing it that way your time with Gruden
we've talked about it so many times you
witnessing him just like tearing into
Sims and all that stuff but Gruden is a
passionate guy Antonio is a passionate
guy how do you think this relationship
goes and for me it looks like a
relationship that could burn super
bright early but I worry about how long
before it burns out do you share that
with me or you the other side no not at
all you know I mean it's all about
what's going on I mean if they're
winning football games and they are
they're having success I mean you know
calling plays catching balls whatever
whatever then I don't think I don't
think this thing would ever burn you
know burn the wrong way you know risky
and it was a very very passionate guy I
mean him a group used to go in at all
the time but I don't think there's a guy
in football that risk in and respects
more than general because you know I
mean you can go actually the way of what
your coach when you're not talking about
personal stuff when you're talking about
trying to be better as a as a player
better as a team then
you know you can you can have a very
intense conversation with your coach you
know so I think from that standpoint you
know and that's all I told Antonio this
look man you know keep this about the
team you know you know if you go to him
and you want to talk to him about the
team you can say anything in the world
to him if you're trying to make this
team better on game day or during a week
you know but you know all the personal
stuff I don't know I don't know if I
recommend you having those kind of
conversation to it yeah I don't see
Gruden taking it well if a B goes I need
more balls that I don't think that's
gonna work out well yeah you know I mean
but at the same time grew that's been
around everybody man around you know
Keyshawn Johnson yeah
you know me so he's been around some
some guys I'm Jerry Rice and you know
you know meteorites you know so I mean
he's been around some attitudes man so
you know I probably was the you know
sports attitude goes the best of the
other bad for because I you know I sort
of act as a coach to the locker rooms
world or so I this is not something
that's new for him you know so he's not
going to panic when I tell you comes off
the field said throw me the doggone ball
no that's not gonna be the first time
he's ever heard that I know that you're
one of those guys that you walk down the
street and everyone wants to know your
take on the Raiders where they're gonna
give you their take on the Raiders have
you had any instances yet about Raider
nation's feeling about this like a there
any funny stories or any moments of
passion no no I think everybody's super
excited you know I put a little quote
out last night on Twitter and you know
ready nation ate it up and but all the
remarks I got back were you know you
know put them in anyone let him or your
number to him or the good that's not my
I don't have anything to do with that he
wants to put on anyone god bless him but
so you know I think that was the only
thing that I got that was sort of funny
everybody wanted to see Brown you know
in 81 so right but we'll see what
happens with all that if he asked you
for 81 would you say yes oh man I have
no say-so on that number they put three
or four people in ad words I've been
going on so as they might be whose last
thing was brown last year weren't 81 so
they need to ask him
I'm gonna be honest the wood I'm still
upset that they're given 81 outs
I mean that's crazy you're right well
you know it's it's it's a thing it's a
rate of way of doing things back you
know it's just how far but at the same
time it's all good I used to tell people
back then let you put that number of you
want to you but just know what people
are gonna expect when you put that
number on you know so that's the thing
you got to know I'm just curious like
when when it happen did you get excited
like did it have an impact on you the
fan inside of you know yes Lily man yeah
yeah absolutely because you know I I had
many conversations with Gruen during the
seats and he kept saying man I gotta
find some playmakers I gotta find some
guys who can do this and do that and now
he has a guy who can do everything so I
think from that standpoint it's a great
starts at all season for them and I'm
sure they're not done
you know they got offensive tackle today
so there are more pieces to this puzzle
to be put together and then and then
Derek card a Antonio Brown some stats
came out over the weekend that Derek
Carr was unbelievable at throwing flats
and outs which I think Antonio's great
at short quick moment movements get the
ball make a man miss how do you think
that bond between those two guys could
work I think I said earlier you know
with your great football players it
doesn't matter who's throwing the ball
you know who who's catching the ball
it's all about doing what you're
supposed to do and I think in this case
man you know it's the first start for
both of these guys not Derek you know
has that go to God that you know he
hasn't had and you know I'm already left
for sure so but now you know they get to
do a whole offseason together come in to
training camp you know work on what they
need to work on and go from there man so
I just this is this is a beautiful thing
here it's and you know I'm happy for the
Raiders first of all and certainly happy
too and tell me what they able to get
his deal settled yeah and now he can go
play football and not have to worry
about all this other great stuff I also
just read that apparently the Raiders
are gonna have you be the chaperone for
a B once he gets to Vegas that's excited
well they give me plus five probably
but look you know it's like they told me
a couple years ago when this all came up
if guys guys to go to Vegas now
everybody and coming back for practice
so you know we can't stop guys from
doing what they're gonna do there's
always gonna be one or two that's gonna
you know run amuck but I think for the
most part you got a [ __ ] football team
you're not gonna try to mess that up
that's awesome hey what do you got going
on right now with this h2h initiative I
want to hear more about it yeah so you
know when I was inducted into the Hall
of Fame I had a buddy in Dallas to to
pull me over said you know and I got to
say it like him otherwise there's no
effect to it he said hey cam do you know
that you only wanted not guys should go
into the Hall of Fame but be a height
which hoping with no saying no bro that
can't be right and obviously when we did
some research and I found out that that
was case you know that and we thought
that was sort of remarkable that only
nine guys had been able to accomplish
this yeah that's wild obviously been
only only only receiver to accomplish it
and Roger Staubach to be the only
quarterback to accomplish it so so we
just thought man you know we've had an
incredible legacy on the football field
left an incredible legacy but now it's
time to leave something off the field so
let's get together let's see if we can
gather some companies let's see if we
can get involved with some nonprofits
and let's go do something great in the
world you know and we don't know exactly
what they do at this particular point
but at the same time we know that we
want to do something and leave a mark
off the football field also and so we're
gonna you know we put it all together
now we'll have more about end of the
year I love it hey Tim I always love
talking to you you're always a class act
and I'm happy there's another Brown on
the Raiders I'm hoping he's not wearing
81 but I'm excited that the Raiders the
positivity is back a b3 first-round
picks Gruden at the helm
it feels good man I appreciate your time
no I appreciate it thank you all right
brother Tim Brown I think it's still
crazy that they're letting 81 get worn
by anybody I mean the dude was there for
like two decades while we were talking
more breaking news too
on Jackson it's apparently three years
27 million thirteen of that is
guaranteed so he got a nice little check
Adam Humphries slot wide receiver from
Tampa Bay is going to Tennessee for
about 8 million per year getting another
inside wide receiver for Marcus Mariota
if he can stay healthy with Corey Davis
on the outside and the other one this
one's interesting Terrell Suggs going to
the Arizona Cardinals interesting played
of course football Arizona State where
he said at that time the all-time sack
record for the NCAA but going to Arizona
Terrell Suggs Chandler Jones we'll see I
think it's an interesting move I think
having Terrell Suggs in your locker room
is always a good thing
he's just that kind of energy and also
he spends his off seasons in Arizona so
all of that makes complete sense all
right so I want to talk to you guys
about one thing and I previewed it in
the beginning about what was happening
with David Irving and his quitting of
the NFL I will openly admit that I came
on this podcast and I said you know it's
time for the Cowboys to move on from
David Irving it's time it's not worth to
deal with it anymore and it's just too
many off the field issues I still
believe that but I have a big problem
with how this story was perceived and
digested by everybody I got the alert as
I'm sure you didn't I said in the
beginning of the show David Irving quits
NFL while smoking marijuana joint on IG
life and in my head like everybody else
probably went the hell is this guy doing
look here you can add um ass like that's
what I thought because the thing that's
always been the notion with weed and we
go back to Stephen a Smith layoff we
hear that we go man you know what if I
had a job interview in a month I could
stop if I had to do this I'd I could
stop and then I went and I watched the
video and I want to share
some clips with you because in my mind I
had never really heard David Irving talk
I would argue that many of you have
never heard David Irving talk and when I
heard him talk I went wow this guy is
not only intelligent this guy may have a
point here is how he did it he logged on
and he said this by the way not suitable
for work there will be curse words but
then he gonna have been cursing so he
came on he said I quit and I watched
that and I went oh man this is this was
bad he's just gonna come in here and do
it but what was interesting is he
started saying the things that we always
talked about he started talking about
opioids he started talking about
addiction in the NFL and he started
talking about how he's looking at it as
a medicinal substitute here's how he
continued as you all know I've voiced my
opinion right here and he holds up a
joint you know we got to deal with that
policy and everyone thinks it's about
smoking weed if it's not about smoking
weed it's much bigger than that much
much bigger house every day and I get to
see around the office how that [ __ ]
your head up he then went on to talk
about all the different types of
medication that are given to NFL players
and they don't even realize what it is
he say in names of drugs I've never
heard catharsis Ian and sarsa gene and
all that stuff and the thing that we
never think about is imagine being a 23
year old player or a 24 year old kid and
you're going to a locker room and you're
just seeing dudes on the table and
you're seeing them taking the drugs and
then you're seeing them go out there and
get more concussions we never think
about the human side with these kids we
never think what it's like to look over
and at a guy like a Shawn Lee or someone
that's been the NFL for a long time and
then them actively having conversations
about what it's gonna be like for them
when they get older when they live with
this we are very willing to look into a
camera and say I'm not gonna let my
child play in the NFL but these are
children playing in the NFL and they're
dealing with a lot of pain and
concussions and this is how they're
dealing with him now I'm cutting up
parts of it to give you the best parts
this is where he lights it up and he
raises a very interesting question about
smoking weed
how many NBA players you see getting in
trouble about this how many coaches you
see getting in trouble about this how
many baseball players get in trouble
how many UFC players getting in trouble
how many actors I got some questions but
everyone questions my my commitment to
football let us get it straight and now
I love football football I mean [ __ ] has
hit me I wouldn't be here without it and
then he continues and one of the things
he said and I hadn't even factored it in
is he would pretty much at this point
probably have to play a season for free
because after a while they just start
taking your checks so then you're taking
marijuana as a medication to help with
concussions and injuries because the NFL
is prescribing you opioids which our own
president is coming out and saying that
it's an absolute crisis in our country
opioid addiction but it's the only sport
because I agree when's the last time you
saw a coach get in trouble for smoking
weed or a baseball player I agree with
everything he say in there he goes so
now I'm gonna go out there for free and
get hit and get further
injured and the only way I'm gonna help
myself as my smoking weed which is then
and it caused me to then get more games
for free he then said a little bit later
on that he's never made even a million
dollars in the NFL we can talk about how
you have to have control but the
conversation is he believes he's having
more control by not taking opioids and I
think that's smart and what do you know
there's an article on espn.com by Emily
Kaplan around the same time it came out
this weekend that brought up an
interesting nugget did you know that 82
percent of all sports franchises NFL
Major League Baseball NBA NHL are in
states that employees can legally
purchase Metta medicinal or recreational
marijuana in all sports over 80 percent
you can buy it rec really SH
recreationally or medicinal in NFL
cities of 32 teams 25 THC is legal 78
percent of the NFL THC is legal but yet
all we hear about our suspensions and
taking away of paychecks in the NHL if
you get tested positive for weed they
offer you a program on the straight and
narrow but you don't have to be a part
of it quote they're looking to see if a
guy needs help it's not seen as one of
these crazy drugs it's seen as being
maybe a sign but it's a question not a
demand and sure as hell not a suspension
the MBA is openly discussing changing
their marijuana possum pop policy Adam
Silver said quote we're gonna try and
follow the science end quote
the NFL really is the only one that's
making it criminal and when I thought
about it I began to realize who does
this benefit the owners the owners can
smoke nothing happens the coaches can
smoke
nothing happens dammit the referees can
smoke and nothing happens but if a
player smokes now he plays for free it's
just an interesting thought process it
I'm not saying that David Irving is a
victim not saying that all David Irving
probably needed to have more control
because of all the testing but at the
same time David Irving brings a very
good point they want to put opioids that
are harmful in our bodies and I'm trying
to take a natural approach that is legal
in 78% of NFL cities what am I doing
wrong and is it really wrong I just
thought it was a story that you probably
glossed over it's my job to read the
fine print I appreciate you guys very
much Tim Brown thank you again so much
for coming in or being on the phone he
is the man and Antonio Brown is
officially a Raider free agency's gonna
rage on later this week a the stick to
football guys will be in here and we're
gonna break down a bunch of the draft
and we're gonna have some big-name
guests coming up next week I don't want
to say their names because I don't want
to jinx it but one of them is Uncle
Chuck and I just jinxed it hopefully
love you guys I am the lef koe and we
will holla holla holla at you guys later
be well dudes peace
[Music]
you